I
think lot of people maybe go through life
without really noticing all of the things
around them and as Course 4’s, we are very
aware of the world around us, and I think
we learn from it, and think of how we can
make the world a better place.
The magical thing about Course 4 is it really
teaches you how to take your creativity and
design ideas and then translate them into
physical realities that are spatial, occupiable,
inhabitable and have kind of powerful cultural
resonance.
I think that all of these different interests
come together in the studio environment; that’s
really where all of our different ideas get
to take form.
Just about all of our studios have a lot of
freedom in our ability to design our own projects
and take our own ideas as far as we can.
You see other people’s projects and you’re
like ‘how did they come up with that?’;
‘how did that mind come up with something
that cool.’
It is a costume for the Galactic Olympics
and it is basically supposed to connect every
part of your body.
The goal is develop new structural systems
using small diameter round timber.
We’re currently on the site of the Collier
Memorial, a structure that is being built
in Sean Collier’s honor.
The basic concept of the project is that it
stands as a long-lasting monument that speaks
to the strength of our community and we designed
it to work in compression, as a series of
stones to be held in place only by gravity.
As an undergrad we’re only used to seeing
small models, but actually blowing it up to
real scale where people can actually pass
by and inhabit the space, is unbelievable.
I specifically really liked the experience
of design reviews, going in front of a group
of people and having to present your work,
and understanding that that is just part of
the process and it can better and you can
build.
Course 4 gave me the opportunity to work in
a professional environment and work alongside
extremely talented and motivated people.
You work so closely with faculty; you talk
so much with professors. You learn something
you can never learn from just taking a class.
The professors learn from you, you learn from
professors.
There are civil engineers, and there are mechanical
engineers, materials scientists and architecture
majors and everyone plays a role. It makes
a lot of sense because architecture is a lot
more interdisciplinary than a lot of  people expect.
It’s so cool to get to work with designers
and engineers at the same time; I think that
really validates the work.
One of the things that I really liked about
MIT was that I was exposed to all different
types of fields; really a great cross-pollination
of disciplines that I think led to what I
do now.
Course 4 brings together architects, designers,
artists, historians, and engineers around
ideas and concepts to transform how we imagine
and construct our environments.
I’ve always thought that the architecture
department teaches you how to solve problems
and its a way of thinking that lets you approach
the unknown.
Theres an incredible amount of support. It’s
almost an expectation that you can immediately
try to make an impact. I think that’s the
really exciting part; it’s not just about
working abstractly, its really about immediately
applying what you’re learning to try to
make the world a better place.